good evening I'm Matthew Spalding
associate vice president Dean for
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
welcome to the Olympic RV center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
we are we have with us this evening a
two very good guests and Friends of the
college and our program this evening is
actually going to be hosted by one of
our friends who actually is previously
adjunct professor here at the Kirby
Center teaching frost teaching
constitutional law Brad Watson is the
Philip M McKenna professor in American
Western political thought and the
co-director of the Center for political
and economic thought st. Vincent College
in Latrobe Pennsylvania he is written in
a number of things he's Canadian we
won't hold that against him since he got
his PhD with our friends out at
Claremont and he's written a book called
living Constitution dying faith
progressives in the new science of
jurisprudence very well-qualified to be
with us this evening he will introduce
our special guests who will give his
remarks and dr. Watson will also be
making some comments after that and
there'll be time for question so thank
you all for coming and I turn it over to
dr. Watson Thank You Matt and thanks to
Kirby for organizing this I will point
out that I am a reformed Canadian and a
reformed lawyer so I don't don't accuse
me of being that right now I'm very
pleased to begin with to introduce our
special guest judge Thomas B Griffith
who is a federal judge on the United
States Court of Appeals for the District
of Columbia judge Griffith received his
undergraduate education at Brigham Young
University and his legal education at
the University of Virginia Law School
where he served on the Virginia Law
Review
he also served for a time as president
and general counsel of BYU where he
served until I think just prior to his
appointment on the on the DC Court and
since joining the court judge Griffith
has taught courses on presidential
powers and judicial process at BYU and
on the role of an article 3 judge at
for Law School he has very distinguished
legal career in addition to this he
practiced from 1985 to 1995 and then a
little bit later in the 90s first in
Charlotte North Carolina
then in Washington DC his primary areas
of emphasis were corporate and
commercial litigation and government
investigations he also served in the
late 90s as Senate legal counsel of the
United States and that capacity he
represented the interests of the Senate
in litigation and advised the Senate
leadership and it's committees on
investigations including the impeachment
trial of President Clinton he's also
served as a member of the United States
Secretary of Education Commission on
opportunity and athletics which examined
the role of title 9 in intercollegiate
athletics and when he was at BYU he
focused on preserving the unique role of
religiously affiliated colleges and
universities in higher education and
interestingly in November 2011 judge
Griffith was included in the New
Republic's list of Washington's most
powerful but least famous people I'm
here to provide a little balance to the
program because I too am among the least
famous people not only in Washington but
in all of America but in addition to
that I'm also one of the least powerful
so well we should have a very balanced
program
[Applause]
yeah that was silly not the introduction
but the the New Republic which is not we
are being recorded so I'll be careful
about what it's about the news I say
about the New Republic great magazine
amazing so I'm honored to be here
I think this invitation started maybe a
year and a half or so ago when dr. Arnn
invited me to come out to Hillsdale
which I would love to do if I had the
capacity to it but I just don't because
I have other teaching commitments and
but I'm a huge fan of the college I
impress gets read the minute it comes to
my doorstep and I am a supporter of its
unique role an American higher education
part of that comes just from my
sensibilities other comes from my
experience as being the general counsel
of Brigham Young University which also
has a very unique and distinctive place
in American higher education and so I
cheer what you do and I'm honored that
that that I would be invited to be here
tonight tonight is is a significant
night in in in many ways there's one way
more than more than any go Bryce come on
he's got to start hitting anyway so
enough of that so what I'd like to to do
go down well that'd be fine that'd be
fine we just got to get past this game
this is important to us Washingtonians
just this game modest hopes my topic
tonight is titled judicial conservatism
in a liberal democracy and it's going to
be a very personal it's I've now been on
the DC circuit since 2005 and have
gathered some experience that gives me
an opportunity to reflect on what's
happened in the last 13 years how's my
views of the role of a judge changed
over time if
if they have but let me start at the
beginning of that with a with a an
anecdote that comes from my confirmation
process I was I was nominated by
president george w bush in in 2004 and
as part of the as part of the process i
found myself in the offices of the then
democratic leader of the senate Tom
Daschle who I actually knew quite well
from my time as the chief legal officer
of the Senate and I was being
interviewed by one of his staffers who I
was told right before the interview was
the chief architect of the democratic
filibuster strategy against President
Bush's nominees so so I had this sense
that this was an important conversation
because I didn't want to be the first
self-interest I didn't want to be the
target of the the filibuster and so I
was a little bit nervous he was very
personable and kind it I think it it
helped some that before I interviewed
with the staffer senator Daschle himself
had come in and had embraced me and said
very nice things about me and so I think
this staffer was trying to figure out
ways like what's going on here here's
this conservative Republican a named
fight george w bush and the boss is
hugging what you know it was a little
bit disoriented then the interview began
and the first question that he asked me
was do you believe in the natural law
and i thought that's an odd place to
begin the interview but i remember you
for those of you who are old enough
remember that was actually the first
issue and justice Thomas's Senate
confirmation hearings before it got
overtaken by some other issue but that
that was the that was the the bone of
contention is because Justice Thomas had
written some articles about the natural
law and I said well yes I do
know I I'm a theist I'm a believing
Christian and yes I believe in the
natural law but I don't have a lot of
confidence and this was good friend
Hadley Arcis cringes what I say this I
don't have a lot of confidence
and a judge's ability to discern that to
use its dispose of cases he liked that
answer as you can imagine and then he
asks the next question which is an
obligatory if you're ever gonna be in
this setting you will be asked this
question it's a easy question and
there's an easy answer to it
so which judge of all American judges
has had the greatest influence on your
thinking about law well a pause for a
second I was a practicing lawyer you
know I took on law and jurisprudence in
law school that had been a long time
before that I I hadn't spent the
intervening time doing a lot of reading
about legal theory I was a member of the
Federalist Society so I had those
sensibilities but I I wasn't
particularly schooled or learned in
judicial philosophy and so the the
answer that I gave - so what's the
answer you're gonna give if somebody
asks you there's an easy answer right
John Marshall right that's that's the
easy answer and that's the answer they
always get right and so so he said okay
other than John Marshall other than John
Marshall and so I the truthful answer
was Robert Bork right but I I paused for
a second before I gave that answer
because I thought now this could get me
into trouble right I mean this you know
this is not going to be an answer that
the architect of the democratic
filibuster strategy is going to take
well and I can remember pausing for a
second and and then realizing well look
you can't lie right I mean this is a
good job to get but you ya lie about it
so bite hard
just tell the truth and so I said some
what kind of sheepishly um Robert Bork
and I was thinking that this was a great
Profile in Courage right I was thinking
I would be able to tell my grandchildren
I missed being on the DC Circuit because
I stood of it it's completely
non-controversial to him he could sense
my reticence and he said look look what
we get that you're conservative pointed
by Bush that's not a problem with me
and so the reason I'm telling you that
story is because I hitched my cart at
that moment to to judge vork and to his
view of judging and that's and that's
that's the the horse I rode into town I
start my story with with that that it
was judge bork's reasoning he's thinking
to the extent that I had read a bit I
hadn't read that much I had read it at
47 Indiana law journal won the neutral
principles I'd read the tempting of
America slouching toward Gomorrah and so
I was generally aware of that that's
where that's where I started from well
now I've got 13 plus years of experience
where am I now how has it worked out how
have judge judge bork's views about the
limited role of a judge play that let me
tell you where I am where I am now a
little bit about the craft of judging or
the limitations of judging most reading
that I do these days is a red brief or a
blue brief or a gray brief sometimes a
green brief its briefs there's that's
that's pretty much all the reading I'm
able to do not a lot of time once again
to read legal theory and that
disappointed me after a couple years on
the bench but I found a way out of that
quandary I was invited to teach a class
at at the Law School to Brigham Young
University they wanted me to teach a
class on the separation of powers I
ended up teaching a class on
presidential powers and it was a killer
I mean I had this a real job with the
judge and tried to do first preparations
in this it was just really difficult one
of the days one of these days I was
mentioning to one of my colleagues
Douglas Ginsburg what I was doing and he
said oh no that that time you're doing
this all wrong this isn't how you teach
as a judge here's how you teach you
identify the ten books you want to read
but you don't have time to read and you
go to the law school you come up with a
fancy name for it but you read those
books and the class reads those books
and I said that's how we get to read
books so I thought
that sounds like a great idea to me so
Stanford came calling would you like to
teach a class and they wanted me to
teach something about my Senate
experience and I said okay try
Ginsburg's idea and so I presented the
idea I would like to teach a class on
the role of the article 3 judge and I
identified the things I wanted to read
and they they bought it they said great
so so my sabbatical each year is three
weeks in January I get to read and to
think and to teach with some engaging
students interact engaging students on
this topic of marieee lamé of the course
I don't put it in the catalogue but the
real name of the course for me is what
sport write did work did work get it
right and I've taught that class at
Stanford I've actually be teaching it at
a janitor MIT at Harvard this years well
here's how the course goes we start with
pork
we start with Scalia those are my people
that's where I started from we start
there and then we say bring on all
comers we read Justice Breyer we read
Dworkin we read Randy Barnett from just
down the street we read Hadley arcus we
read Richard Posner II read Cass
Sunstein and and once each one is sort
of taking on the the Bork Scalia view
and here's my report after 13 years of
judging and after teaching this course
for now six or seven years I think works
wrong hold on that was intended to wake
you up a little bit I think it was wrong
in this sense we're he's an originalist
I'm an originalist we're looking for the
original public and the understanding of
phrases in the Constitution in the
phrase here is the judicial power what
did the phrase mean to the to the to
those who drafted the Constitution for
those who ratified it what did it mean
I'm not a historian of course the real
serious limitation with originalism
right is that judges aren't historians
okay but we try and do history because
it's I think it's the only faithful way
to
to read the Constitution to apply it so
the history that I've done such as it is
I don't think the framers had in mind
the type of judge the judge Bork had in
mind I think what they had in mind and
what the public understood at the time
was more along the lines of a common law
judge a common law judge who was trying
to do justice the way
Dworkin would have me do or a common law
judge who was trying to come up with
fair and sensible pragmatic equitable
results the way Judge Posner would have
me do or a common law judge who was
trying to find what Liberty means as
Randy Barnett what happened ooh or was
trying to give meaning to the
unenumerated rights as hadley arcus
would have me do
but there's a problem with that they may
not have had in monk they may not have
had in mind the type of judge that judge
Bork and Justice Scalia want me to be
but they created a system of government
they created a structure of government
for what's the most fundamental Liberty
of all right is the liberty of the
people to create the laws by which
society will be governed and they came
up with a very intricate lawmaking
function right bicameralism presentment
that involves only political actors
right only people who are politically
accountable that's that's the gist of
the idea right that's the gist of the
experiment that the laws are going to be
made by politically accountable
representatives of We the People the
most fundamental Liberty of all and in
that system there is no place for the
judge that Ronald Dworkin wants or the
judge I think Richard Posner wants I
think there's no place no real place for
the common law judge who's trying to do
fairness and equity
there's the place for a judge who is not
quite the extreme view of Thomas
Jefferson of you know a mere Claire in a
clerk but not much beyond that it's a
judge's responsibilities more clerical
than anything else in the sense and
Felix Frankfurter put it this way
judges are mere translators of the
values that are expressed by We the
People in the Constitution and laws a
story to illustrate this and then off
the boss comment it was the day that I
was confirmed by the Senate to be on the
court a happy day happy day in my life I
was in my office at BYU and I was the
recipient of a number of congratulatory
phone calls and one of them came from a
fellow fellow who had been a partner I
was a partner partner of his at my law
firm in Washington DC he had he had
clerked for a rather distinguished judge
on the DC Circuit and then de Klerk for
a noted justice of the Supreme Court and
he called and he said Tom he said I've
been a careful observer of judges and
justices throughout my life and that may
I give you some advice
and I said please do that this is a
teachable moment I am teachable tell me
what to do he said well he said I'll
share with you the advice that my judge
on the DC Circuit gave me the first day
of his chambers so the judge brought me
in and sat me down and said this is how
we go about doing our business the first
thing that we do is we learn the facts
of the case as best we can because these
are real people and they deserve to know
that we know there are circumstances
that's the first thing we do the second
thing we do is we think long and hard
and deep about the fair result the just
disposition the equitable thing to do
and once we have figured that out we go
find law to support our decision well it
was a congratulatory call the purpose
was not to engage in an extended
discussion of the role of an article 3
but as I thanked him for the call and
hung up the phone I took a vow to myself
and to God that I would do everything in
my power to heed the first part of his
counsel which was to learn the facts of
the case as best they can to use it
affects people's lives and to never give
in to the temptation to do the second
that I would never try and decide what's
the fair result what's the just result
what's the equitable result because
that's not my job the American people
decide what's fair and equitable and
just and they put it in the Constitution
they put it in acts of Congress they put
it in powers the president exercises
with delegated authority and they get to
decide that and my job is to be a
faithful agent to that even when I think
they're wrong right even when I think
they're wrong as far as I understand it
that's the oath that's the oath that I
take in a white why is this important
well Bork identified correctly that when
judges lose track of this and replace
the value judgments of the American
people put into law with their own
finely tuned and refined sense of what's
right and what's wrong what you have
effectively done is ruined the whole
project right let's go back to high
school civics not taught much anymore
but in for most of us here some of this
probably didn't get most of us here we
had it you remember remember that little
cartoon how a bill becomes a law when I
was going through is you know the funny
little guy with a you know with scrolls
under his arms and you'd follow them
around and it was to teach you how
ability comes along you go back to that
it's still won't they have online
versions now nowhere in that wonderful
little teaching device do you see a
judge there's no judge in there in our
system judges cannot be lawmakers
because if
we are it undermines the entire project
law and our system has to be made by
politically accountable representatives
of We the People
so my cautionary note to my fellow
conservatives is that we must never lose
sight of that extremely limited role of
judges and there's a temptation to lose
sight of that right III was I was not
there on the day of the founding of the
Federalist Society at Yale in 1985 but I
was there right afterwards from the
get-go been a deeply committed member of
the Federalist Society deeply committed
to their vision and in those days when
we were first gathering this was what we
told each other this is what we told he
so the judges have limited roles they
there's a difference between a judicial
conservative and a conservative who's a
judge right we can't be results where we
and that was what we told each other all
the time
well a generation almost two generations
later now we have lots of conservatives
who'd become judges and the question
that I have for us is are we holding
fast to that that vision of what a
judicial conservative is or are we
yielding to the temptation to use the
judiciary to reach the outcomes that
that our sensibilities and our values
favor and if we do we've lost sight of
something really critical and important
and so it's it's my I'm in now in
evangelizing mode to my fellow
conservatives we can't give in to that
that that temptation it the law has to
be made by the political branches and
sometimes you win and sometimes you lose
but it's the political branches it's the
politically accountable representatives
we the people that have to do the heavy
lifting in attempting to create the calm
well that we we all hope and pray for so
with that thank you very much it'd be a
little intimidating it was behind me I'm
gonna give some remarks and then we'll
take some Q&A yeah okay I think I've
been brought on to lob a rhetorical bomb
or two in the direction of the judiciary
so that's what I'll do and I'll begin by
saying I think the state of judicial
conservatism of originalism if you will
and of our liberal democracy of which it
is and must be a vital part is not good
indeed I would say the future of the
federal judiciary is not bright and this
probably won't be fixed by carefully
cultivating the right sorts of judges
through the best Federalist Society
channels and hoping the right president
gets elected to appoint them after all
where has this approach gotten us really
over the last several decades
respectable people are now openly
calling for constitutional office
holders to ignore clear light
anti-constitutional judgments of the
Supreme Court this has made clear in the
2015 scholars statement on the
obergefell case which I had some hand in
drafting how did this situation come to
be how did the least dangerous branch in
Hamilton's telling become so dangerous
when it comes to the direction of our
nominally self-governing Republic as the
anti-federalists Brutus said of the
members of the proposed court there is
no power above them to control any of
their decisions there is no authority
that could remove them they cannot be
controlled by the laws and the
legislature in short they are
independent of the people of the
legislature and of every power under
heaven men placed in this situation will
generally soon feel themselves
independent of heaven itself they will
in other words be most unlike members of
a good English common law court and I
agree with judge Griffith here that I
think
founders wanted that in judges we now
see case after case wherein we observe a
marked tendency of four or five justices
of the court to read into the
Constitution clearly unenumerated rights
or protections pick your favorite from
same-sex marriage or the purported right
to be free from capital or other
punishments one could go on while
reading out of the Constitution clearly
enumerated rights second Amendment right
the state of affairs is not healthy it
cannot last if we are to be a
self-governing people such cases show
dispositively that a majority or near
majority depending on the case of our
judicial Emperor's have no clothes they
cannot possibly be viewed as doing
constitutional interpretation but rather
I think a kind of evolutionary sociology
we and they should stop pretending
otherwise as a Justice Thomas noted in a
dissent in an eighth amendment case
reported reasons for judgment are often
merely ornaments in the courts analysis
window-dressing that accompanies its
judicial Fiat he knows that judges find
the law as it were to support there are
moral preferences I would submit that
everybody left and right in America
knows this and knows it perfectly well
that's why judicial nominations have
become morality plays and kabuki dances
the ultimate form of overwrought
political theater the fact that both
left and right agree on the one very
important and profoundly disturbing
thing which is this much of the future
of our constitutional republic hinges on
who the next Justice of the Supreme
Court will be the fact that one person
exercises this kind of power
I think should cause everyone to step
back and see that the court has become
far too powerful for anyone's good hence
the call for political resistance
constitutional resistance in the
obergefell statement I want to take a
moment to compare our sad situation to
the actual Constitution the founders
thought they were created in the
tradition of moral
realism the founders rejected assaults
ancient and modern on our capacity to
know and to follow moral truths their
politics rested on a fact of nature a
certain understanding of natural law the
political equality of human beings the
founders did not embrace the
self-evident falsehood of equality in
all respects but the self-evident truth
that no man is born so sufficiently
superior to another to be entitled to
rule without the consent of the other
hence legitimate government is rooted in
the compact of politically equal beings
and depends for its operation on the
continuing consent of the governed as
judge Griffith has said the founders
moral realism held with Plato in the -
that law aims to be a discovery of what
is and with Aquinas in the Summa that
all law to be law must align with a
natural law God's reason about the moral
order our Constitution is therefore
grounded theoretically in the
sovereignty of the people it's been
reduced practically to the sovereignty
of the government increasingly
government by judiciary the intellectual
movement that precipitated this shift
was American progressivism American
progressivism has dominated American
political thought since the age of
Lincoln as I'm sure many of you know it
embodies a philosophy of history with a
capital H not history as a record of
events but history that's going
somewhere that is unfolding inexorably
in a direction that's largely screw the
ball to elites with everything in motion
a constitution dedicated to preservation
must itself be overcome furthermore a
constitution premise taun the idea that
there are truths that transcend the
unfolding of history truths that do not
vary with time is intellectually an
absurdity for the progressives for
progressives the foundation of morality
and politics rests not on the cognizable
facts of nature but in the unfolding of
rational will the process by which this
comes to past is historical time
corrects all errors and the future takes
care of itself in the words of Benjamin
Cardozo
and tempted to say the immortal words
just to confound him we must look to the
future to see where we should go now
we cannot look back as Lincoln did to
musty dusty historical documents like
the Constitution a philosophy of history
of one form or another is needed to
describe an account for this process and
history indeed comes to be the way in
which we are at least our elites
understand politics and
constitutionalism American elites have
imbibed not merely progressivism but in
the extremity of liberalism a
contemporary form of nominalism words
have come to mean what the smart people
in control of the organs of the state
think they should mean based on their
sense of our historically revealed
preferences we seek judicial expertise
not so much to reveal and direct what
the earlier progressives saw as the
ironclad laws of history and value free
social science but rather to tell us
where our psyches are situated in the
unfolding of emotional history to do
this government needs to assume the
power to define and indeed to eliminate
words themselves this is a power that
big brother in Orwell's 1984 knew was
critical to his task
thoughtcrime will be impossible when
there are no words left in which to
express it our new nominalist
progressives are still under the sway of
a philosophy of history but their's as
an inchoate faith in the future resting
most approximately on decidedly American
philosophical doctrines like social
Darwinism and pragmatism the latter
particularly UC writ large in the in the
writings of Judge Posner who keeps by
the way writing the same book over and
over and over again just to make that
very point to the pragmatism is
everything at its heart of this
nominalism as a Darwinian sense that we
must by definition evolve or die we must
keep up with the times as revealed in
allegedly more advanced places other
social democracies in particular let's
see what the Europeans are doing let's
see what the Canadians are doing and
this Darwinian sense of the necessity
for change in the need to embrace change
coupled with American pragmatism z'
philosophical approval of individual and
social experiments militate very
strongly against both constitutionalism
and nature as a
standard it's therefore a mistake I
think to overemphasize any highfalutin
doctrine like German idealism say
Hegelian ism is the foundation of this
American progressivism the age of high
Hegelian ISM or at least relatively high
by American standards died with Woodrow
Wilson on February 3rd 1924 this new
nominalism is much looser more
comprehensive more American and harder
to combat than a single German
philosophical doctrine the most striking
examples of it of words coming to be
understood by elites not to refer to
anything in nature but to float freely
above things in themselves are to be
found in courts of what used to be long
nowadays as I've mentioned even the word
marriage is casually divorced from all
traditional and natural significations
from the wisdom of the ages and from the
shared rational faculties of human
beings which cannot help but see the
male-female distinction as the most
obvious articulation of the laws of
nature and nature's God courts feel free
not simply to twist or ignore the
meaning of words in political documents
like federal or state constitutions but
also in the Oxford English Dictionary
this is a wholly new thing in the
common-law world and with this the brave
new world begins there's literally no
constraint on the power of political
actors state actors to do and by the
manipulation of language to make us
think as they please if you don't accept
the new meanings assigned to words you
will be a pariah you will not be killed
at least not yet
but you will be shunned physically
threatened shamed and driven out of
business resistance is futile is the
message our betters wish us to hear and
it is the ultimate point of the new
judicial nominalism adopted by shameless
usurpers masquerading as judges finders
fabricators fabulous --tz-- in this
system a constitution cannot be
antecedent to government including
government by
Ishi arey because there are no longer
any antecedents all meaning is to be
constructed we look for our guidance
prospectively rather than
retrospectively and so when contemporary
progressives in effect say come let us
build ourselves a city and a tower whose
top is in the heavens let us make a name
for ourselves they do nothing more than
express the earliest and most powerful
of human desires the heart wants what
the heart wants because understanding
can no longer even begin to tame the
heart's desire we no longer merely
ignore or construe a constitutional text
to suit the needs of the administrative
state and its growing list of clients we
deny the moral universe which is
something that even Kant or Hegel did
not quite do at some point in all of
this we either roll over or we fight I
say we fight we have some time for
questions I'm doing double duty I'm
acting as MC here I mean I'm sure we've
said nothing controversial so they
probably aren't any questions but if
there are we've got some time and you
might want to
professor Watson by what means do you
wish us to fight if the federal society
and and such things are futile how what
do we do I didn't say the Federalist
Society was futile I said we are not
likely to win with the old method of you
know working our way up through the
traditional ranks we picked the right
case where public opinion is decisively
on the side of let's say
constitutionalism if not common sense
and then the most obvious the most
direct way I think to challenge
anti-constitutional judicial decisions
is through political action again the
most direct form of that would be
executive non-enforcement for example so
I think you find exactly the right case
where public opinion is clearly on the
side you get the camels nose under the
tent you demonstrate it can be done the
case that I thought was perfect for this
just to give you a concrete example was
the boumedienne case where the Supreme
Court said essentially there is sort of
federal general habeas corpus rights for
non American citizens who have never set
foot on American soil being held in
military determines they overturned the
DC Circuit good and that's an important
important footnote now there's a perfect
case where it seemed to be a george w
was president at the time public opinion
was overwhelmingly on the side of not
let's say not on the side of the people
affected by this judgment right there
was no domestic constituency when
President Obama tried to close Gitmo you
so there's no real domestic constituency
for um let's say legal nicety when it
comes to people in Gitmo there's a
perfect example of a case where you've
got public opinion on your side you have
something completely in the control of
the president the president could have
said that's a very interesting decision
but make me I'm the commander in chief
and these people are no litera custody
Thank You Marshall to get Moe I don't
think so so you pick your case very
carefully as I say you get the camels
nose under the tent but I mean their
other methods do I mean limiting
appellate jurisdiction impeachment
throughout but those are those are
harder I mean you can do this directly
through
think executive enforcement that would
be my first dress you didn't ask me but
I have a different take although
although it's it's not appropriate for
me to venture into the political field
and talk about political action but I
think we do have a different sense I I'm
not certain that I disagree with with
your assessment of the the lay of the
land I think we might have a
disagreement about what to do and and
and and all I can offer here is the
judges can't do much right that if I'm
going to be consistent with the argument
I gave before judges have a very limited
rule I'm not a political scientist I'm
not a historian but to me much of the
problems that have been identified and I
would that are significant front ones
the very is a cultural problem right and
that's going to be best
I think addressed by constituent
elements of civil society that should be
addressing is it there's another problem
and and that is the judiciary is too
powerful it's too powerful in large
measure because the American people
through their elected representatives
have decided to politicize every nook
and cranny of American public life
American life not just public life right
as the the federal government has grown
in such great powers and now regulates
everything well with those regulations
law follows and you need to have
arbiters of disputes regarding the laws
and that's that's us that's where we
come in that's why we are hearing cases
today about matters that hundred years
ago no one would have thought belongs to
the judiciary because Congress and the
federal government hadn't had enacted
there so so once again although I said
I'm not going to get into a political
discussion I mean it's a it's a it's
it's it's it's it's a political issue
that has to be addressed through
the political branches pare back
government you have less problem with
with judges making decisions that have
such far-reaching I don't said how your
understanding of the judicial powers of
the United States says in the light of
the role the common law judge is
consistent with your conclusion on the
looted power of the judge on the
unlimited power of a judge unless you
were thinking of the way common law
judges interpreted statutes how English
statutes instead of torts and contracts
you know when I talk so I maybe I wasn't
precise enough when I was talking about
the type of common law judge I'm
referring to I'm talking about the
common law judge who for example in tort
law and others is deciding what's fair
and equitable and just right the the the
the the great wise judge who's telling
us what justice means I don't think they
I don't think there's a role in our
constitutional structure for that type
of player wearing a robe as a judge that
those decisions are to be made through
elected representatives through the
political branches but not not the
judges as I understand it that's that's
kind of my understanding that's kind of
fun to the fundamental decision that the
framers made that the American
experience is built upon is that those
sorts of decisions about what's fair and
equitable politically accountable
representatives and that's not me right
I'm not politically accountable except
an extreme kit you said the word impeach
and I got a little nervous that except
an industry I mean for all practical
purposes that you've only impeached
judges who haven't paid their income
taxes and things like that so I'm not
politically accountable you don't want
me to be right you want me to have a
measure of Independence so that even
though I was appointed by the Bush
administration when the Bush
administration appears in front I don't
and I'm not obligated to that that's
what we want that sort of independent
you don't want me politically
so therefore as I understand the
American experience I'm not the type of
person who ought to be making law in any
form or fashion and and I think that
that that's new the system the framers
set up doesn't allow for that type of
judging even though it's a historical
matter and then what I say as a
historical matter big caveat because I'm
not a historian it's a historical matter
if we were able to interview the the
framers they they might have had in mind
a judge with with a wig and a colored
gown and trying to decide what's fair
and equitable
there's no oxygen in the room for that
type of type of judge so did I answer
that right
yeah yeah yeah well I mean I tried to
give it to you I think I think it's an
argument based on this structure what
does it mean what it whatever they it
meant what they created was one that
didn't allow for a post an Aryan or
Dworkin judge be clear that I want
judges to be independent to what I'm
really arguing for is a kind of vigorous
departmental ISM the understanding that
in the minds of judges and in the minds
of everyone else that when judges behave
transparently politically they should
expect in fact they are asking for
political pushback I like to remind
every constitutional office holder that
he or she is sworn to uphold the
Constitution of the United States not
the expressed preferences of five people
who once went to law school that's not
the that's not their office it's not
anyone's office let's go to Mike so
given that the separation of powers was
originally so based on the idea of each
branch of government trying to preserve
its independence this curious is an
originalist you know how do you deal
with the fact that say often Congress
doesn't want to even preserve a lot of
its constitutional role so I was a know
trying to answer it that way I was on
the the panel of the DC Circuit that
first heard the null caning case the
recess appointment case and I can just I
didn't write the opinion chief judge
Sentell did I joined the opinion I can
tell you about my questioning at oral
argument as a NOLA Francisco stood
before me the questioning I asked him
was so what what do we to do in a
circumstance where if we conclude that
the executive and the Senate have both
played around with the concept of recess
appointment because they found it
inconvenient and they struck their own
accommodation as to what the meaning of
what what what are we supposed to do in
in that in that in that circumstance I
don't remember his answer but the
Supreme Court came up with an answer and
that is you abide by that right that's
the sort of the fundamental learning of
what Justice Breyer had to say is that
we have this almost 200 years of
cooperation between the executive and
the Senate he didn't phrase it this way
but I would that seems to run afoul of
what the recess appointment Clause
wasn't was intended you what do we do in
that circumstance and his answer is sort
of a departmental list answer it's not
one that I'm necessarily comfortable
with my views on a matter like this I
think are more consonant with perhaps
what justice Thomas's would be and that
is no wait wait a second if it's if if
it's clear in the Constitution what
something means well that you apply that
and that the political branches have
ignored that over you they're not
they're not permitted to do that so so
yeah that that's my my view of what the
one of the limited rules the gshare is
to police the boundaries particularly
with structural boundaries that it
created a not to look separation of
powers is a powerful obviously powerful
I get you know just just Scalise to
teach this so beautifully you know you
probably all heard his stump speech on
this where he said you know you know in
any tinhorn dictator in a banana
republic has a bill of rights the Bill
of Rights don't give you a liberty it's
the separation of powers that do so this
is pretty this is pretty pretty
fundamental and and and and all of that
all I'm overstating here but but much of
the the political pressure is to
disregard that right because the
separation of powers get in the way they
create gridlock they slow government
down the political branches seem to not
care about the separation of powers as
much as I think we would like to do in
that setting I think the judiciary has a
critical role to play to say stop and
get back in here and get back
your lanes because much is it at stake
the only force more powerful than a
progressive majority of the Supreme
Court dr. Arne has commandeered the
microphone so thank you both it was
really great thank you your honor for
coming here for the first time so I want
to invite you to go further in your last
answer because I have to ask my law
clerk if I booked you for it all right
yeah yeah no he's okay I'm okay okay
yeah who is that kid we'll get you a
better one soon
the so that if the people who is
referring next year I have a my chambers
Garret West yeah and he's not as dumb as
he looks so if the people rule and
they've they've told you two things
they've told everybody in the government
two things they've told through their
representatives a bunch of laws wait so
many one can't count them anymore and
then they've made the one law directly
they've made one law directly they made
it themselves they made the Constitution
and so it's a big deal isn't it if that
four thousand word document is to govern
the eighty-seven thousand pages of
federal law made last year and every
other year forever and if you're
policing that that's huge that's a big
thing and it's and and so I invite you
to be less modest about yourself that's
a big thing isn't it and it is the thing
because the situation you're in and it's
not like the common law the situation
you're in is the people pass the law and
then one of them come before you and if
they are punished according to any other
law that violates that law that is
actually a violation of their natural as
well as their legal rights I wonder if
you agree with all right and I don't
disagree with you on the big thing no
it's it's hugely importance why I'm
talking about
right it's why I'm in the mode of
evangelizing to my fellow conservatives
how critically important it is that you
judiciary do its job
now what its job is is I think narrowly
defined but you've identified it it is
to apply the law and not to make it up
right I mean and we say now something
something that I actually cheer so I
when I give talks like this I'm
frequently asked about you called it a
kabuki I think it's right the the
liturgy that has developed in Senate
confirmation hearings such that everyone
in recent memory has said the things
that I'm saying right and said it better
than that I have said and so so what
what do we make of that fact that we
have all of these justices who said this
and yet we have decisions that arguably
I want to be careful about it and that
stopped me here arguably don't seem to
be completely consistent with that
perhaps one could make the argument what
do we do with that
well the cynical view and but that maybe
you see realistic view is that that that
that liturgy was just empty ritual and
meaningless and the realpolitik is
judges as political actors right that
maybe I don't know for me I'm just glad
that we have the ritual right because
it's a new ritual it's a it's a new
liturgy and I think it makes at least
some difference I am really glad when I
hear a nominee of any president yet up
and say it's the law all the way down
Justice Kagan great response when
senator senator Kyl said well you know
she wasn't a judge then she miss Kay
ghen you know if 95% of judging is
applying is the law
don't wouldn't you admit that 5% of it
has to do with your emotions and your
passions and your empathy this is from
Jon Kyl
and Senator rate the bunking senator of
Arizona and and and now Justice Kagan
said no no it's the law all the way down
all the way down now you you can debate
about whether she has lived true to that
VI you know but it was said and I think
that public recitation of that is
critically important now the key is to
reduce the gap between which is the true
of us in all of our lives the gap
between the professed and and the real
but I like to hear that professed and
and and for that I give a great deal of
credit to the Federalist Society I give
a great deal of credit to jurist like
Justice Scalia who have changed the
debate and to Robert Bork have changed
that the the the the debate so that at
least at the very least lip service is
said to that hopefully there might be a
worthwhile clarification on this
question of common law judging we can
find quite easily I think actual
examples of common law judging and a
large administrative state if we look at
England which of course is the finish
legal system is the foundation of the
American legal system judges in England
not in Canada anymore because they've
gone crazier than an American judges
have but in England the birthplace of
the common law you still see common law
judging in a large complex
administrative state where there are
thousands of pages of statutes to be
interpreted and what you can find there
I think is on a case-by-case basis
courts trying to do justice being
equitable right with a merger of law and
equity in the English courts they're
trying to do the equitable thing so for
example a criminal statute if it seems
to be coming down particularly hard on a
particularly unfortunate person a common
law judge in England might find a way to
you know bring the law down a little
less harshly find the law as it were to
do justice what that judge never does in
England is say to Parliament oh by the
way you are not entitled to pass future
laws like that right ever because we say
so Parliament of course is still supreme
and there is a political body the Law
Lords the house
Lorde's - in a way superintend the the
judiciary so there are actually models
of common-law judging in complex
societies that that we come up to and
the anti-federalists were on top of this
as I suggested they realized that
American judges somehow would not be
like what I think a lot of the
Federalists thought they would be like
which is more like an English common law
we have time for one more question so do
you think the federal judiciary has any
role in regulating gerrymandering and
will given that especially the
politicians who would otherwise do it
have a big interest in not doing it I
can look now there are no there are no
constitutional or judicially cognizable
standards when it comes to electoral
districts this is wholly you know a
one-man one-vote it so it's a
fabrication of the Supreme Court look at
justice frankfurters dissent in one of
the early cases the answers there okay
your honor doctor thank you
[Applause]